who's the greatest poker player of all
time and why is it Phil Hellmuth so this
is for Phil uh so he's known
um
at least in part for maybe playing
sub-optimally and he still wins a lot
it's a bit chaotic so maybe
can you speak from an AI perspective
about the genius of his Madness or The
Madness of his genius
so playing sub optimally playing
chaotically
um as a way to make you hard to pin down
about what your strategy is so okay the
thing that I should explain first of all
was like Nash equilibrium it doesn't
mean that it's predictable the whole
point of it is that you're trying to be
unpredictable now I think when somebody
like Phil Hellmuth might be really
successful is not in being unpredictable
but in being able to
um
take advantage of the other player and
figure out where they're being
predictable
or guiding the other player into
thinking that you have certain
weaknesses and then and then
understanding how they're going to
change their behavior they're going to
deviate from a Nash equilibrium style of
play to try to take advantage of those
perceived weaknesses and then
counter-exploit them so you kind of get
into the Mind Games there